I'm a massive fan of yours and I first
like a lot of people I first saw you in
The Walking Dead and that's when you
started coming on the show and you just
pop on the screen you're so authentic
you're so and and you have such power as
an actor and it surprised me when I
learned later on you didn't figure that
out that you had this that acting was a
possibility until a little later in the
game you were in college right yeah yeah
it was it you know what there just
wasn't really anything kind of Around Me
growing up that that that that that that
made me you know I had nobody really in
my life that that did it and right and
um you know I don't know I think now you
know being a dad and seeing seeing my
kids and and you know my kids like to
play with action figures a lot and and I
saw I saw my oldest son Henry the other
day kind of doing I used to do that a
lot I used to play these little games
and act out parts and and uh so I guess
I was doing a lot of that I think I had
a pretty wild imagination but yeah no no
no real no no real window into didn't do
a lot of Youth Theater that's for sure
right well you were very heavily into
you know boxing yeah I was into uh some
martial arts and some boxing a lot of
sports baseball football and and just
that was just kind of a knucklehead I
just kind of was was getting into
trouble left and right and really kind
of lost honestly I had really good
friends but
um yeah I I I I I I think I lacked I
think I lacked Direction so you feel
like it could have gone badly for you
but you but but you got off on the wrong
exit or you took the right turn and that
got you into acting yeah look I mean I I
I I I met a woman uh I was blessed to
meet a woman in in college I took a an
acting class literally by accident
um I thought I was signing up to intro
to Theater which was going to be 150
people in a big theater I thought I
could maybe drop acid and watch movies
that's what I heard
but I ended up being the complete so
many courses because of that you know
what I mean uh yeah so but being the
[ __ ] bag that I was I ended up uh you
know in this small intro to acting class
with very serious you know acting majors
and and and and and kids who really took
it seriously and I'd never really been
around kids like that before and um you
know there was an exercise that that we
had to talk about uh we had to bring in
something that was really important to
to us and share it with the class like a
game of show and tell on steroids and
and the level of emotion that these kids
had sharing these objects I just
couldn't believe it going on for 10
minutes about you know some corn cob
pipe that their Pap Pap had given them
or you know some Blues Traveler CD that
their boyfriend had given them and then
it got to me and I forgot I just didn't
have any anything I I totally you know
as as always just totally botched the
assignment so I just grabbed my
catcher's glove before I was going to
baseball practice and I launched into
this story about how my mom had died and
she gave me this glove on her deathbed
and my mom is totally alive and well
and and and as I was telling the story
I'm like crying my freaking eyes out and
everybody in the room is is crying their
eyes out I'm like whoa whoa whoa hang on
y'all I'm just I'm just doing the acting
I I like I don't and this woman Alma
Becker I have her tattooed here she she
cleared the class out and like ripped me
apart for violating the sanctity of her
Studio but then she was like you know
you you've got something and your
punishment is you gotta you gotta
audition for this this play that I'm
directing and that was my first show and
then after you know I didn't finish
school I got in some some pretty big
trouble and Alma came to me again and
she said look if you really want to do
this I'll get you an audition to to go
to Moscow and the Moscow Art Theater and
that's the reason why I went out there
and she really she she really saved my
life and and ended up marrying my wife
and I and I mean it's a true Testament
to I I just think that the power of of
Educators and teachers and believing in
somebody especially somebody who's lost
and and and who has no real great talent
or no you know I could fight a little
bit I could I could play a little bit of
sports but I wasn't going to do anything
special with them but she saw something
in me and and she jumped on it I think
now as a parent I'm even more there's
this new profound kind of understanding
or or gratitude that that I have for her
and for teachers in general who who do
that and I just I hope that these people
you know come into my kids lives you
know they will I mean that's the other
thing too is I I reflect on my life
especially starting out I'm very aware
that it's not just one person it's kind
of like what you're describing there's
several key people along the way to me
it's it's there's you know because I
grew up in Boston and nobody I didn't
know anybody in Show Business I mean and
I used to be interested in it and really
love watching uh comedies and Comedians
and the classics but I had if someone
had said oh you could do that for a
living I'd have said what do you how
right there's no way to do that I don't
come from that
so I had plotted a completely different
course and but if I look at it now there
are key people there's like someone you
know in high school who really made a
difference but then there's someone
really key my freshman year in college
who encouraged me and then I can just
see this whole Arc of people telling me
this is the way to go follow follow this
and that connection that connection from
loving it and then doing it yourself do
you is there is there a key moment for
you was that a was that moment full of
fright or trepidation yes a total fear I
mean I used to I there was a lot of
different levels to it but the first was
um learning that when I wrote that I
could write things that would make
people laugh and I did that and so I
thought okay I can do this I can write
things that make people laugh but then I
realized that one of the ways that I
wrote was to act things out in front of
people and they would say no no do that
and I would and
um that I could make my friends laugh
and my way of writing a lot was to act
something out and so they would say
right so if you just did that yourself
uh but it took it took a lot of you know
it took a lot of uh making mistakes uh
and uh getting my ass handed to me many
times in many different ways but
um
it really was when I look back on the
whole thing I call it Google Earth if
you zoom out and look at your life and
you can see the whole area I can see oh
wow like there's like along the way
there's maybe 15 different people that
it's crucial moments it's like a pinball
they knock it towards the right
direction that's right you know it's
like a little flipper that gets me going
the right way and then I start to start
to wander off in another little flipper
just gets me going in the right
direction again so I that's why I I
think great humility
I like people that are humble because
you understand
how much you relied on other people and
and as you know being in this business
and I'm not just talking about our
business uh uh of show the business of
show I think is what uh Sammy Davis Jr
called it
um I'm not just talking about that I'm
talking about you see people in finance
you see people who have achieved things
and they have money and they have status
and they think that they did it all it's
crazy and it makes that makes me insane
and I meet them all the time you know
you meet those people all the time and
they're like well I have this nice car
because I am who I am and I made it
happen because I'm great yeah and it's
like no no no you you do not understand
how incredibly fortunate you were many
different times for sure and I think the
fact is is that um I don't know what I
love most about this is is uh how often
you fail and and how often you don't
know what the hell you're you're doing
and how how terrified you are before
something starts and and I think
you know embracing that and diving into
that is is
uh at least for me that's that's that's
something that I I I try to do
um but I'm also really really aware that
this could have gone either way so many
times and
I think that the humility of of of
understanding that it's really the the
buoys along the path it's these great
people that led you this way or this way
if if you're not really aware of that
you're not going to see them
you know as you keep going and and for
me it's not just
um the great teachers that I had in
Russia those great coaches that I had I
mean my my best friend Dougie Thornell
we grew up watching movies together
that's what we did and we would sneak
into Goodfellas and watch it over and
over again We snuck into the sounds of
the Lambs watched it over and over again
and it was so long so long I mean
decades before I'd ever be able to you
know sort of exercise those kinds of
muscles as an artist I mean my first
five ten years I was a tree or I was you
know I was these old sort of avant-garde
you know told Brett characters that had
nothing to do with the stuff that I was
raised on but it was always I still to
this day anything I do I try to take it
back to the Dougie Thornell test the two
of us sitting on his couch used to duct
tape the the remote control to a ping
pong paddle and and he would laugh his
ass off at stuff and he would and I'm
like would this make Dougie laugh you
know what would this do to Dougie and
it's a huge it's a huge part of
everything thing that I do and I wanna I
wanna find the next person and you never
know who that person's gonna be and it's
oftentimes I think not the genius that
we think we're gonna cross it's this
this person that comes into our life and
if our our hearts are open our eyes are
open we'll see it